il n'y a pas assez de superlatifs pour
décrire l'affrontement titanesque qui
oppose à hitler et staline
ce fut la plus grande campagne militaire
de l'histoire impliquant le plus grand
nombre de participants avec les pertes
les plus lourdes où se déroule à la plus
grande bataille de chars jamais vu
les conditions climatiques à l'est de
l'été caucasien brûlant au froid extrême
de l'hiver arctique vers leningrad
c'est là que les hommes du groupe
d'armées nord combattirent et moururent
toujours à court de renforts et de
matériel il se considérait eux mêmes
comme les oubliés du front russe
et c'est sans surprise qu'ils
baptisèrent le conflit dans lequel il
était engagé comme la guerre éternelle
du pauvre soldat
la plupart de ces pauvres soldats du
groupe d'armées nord ne devait jamais
rentrés en allemagne les exigences
incessantes du plus cruelle des conflits
de l'histoire allait finalement faire de
l'ensemble du groupe d'armées sa victime
[Musique]
le groupe d'armées nord
à la fin 2009 140 adolf hitler annonce à
son état-major qu'il avait pris la
décision irrévocable d'attaquer la
russie
il suivrait un plan rapidement élaboré
qui reposait sur trois percées
effectuées par trois importants groupes
d'armées rassemblant un total de trois
millions et demi d'hommes
la stratégie générale la demande
consistait en trois grandes avancées
parallèle la première visant leningrad
au nord la seconde moscou au centre et
pour la troisième odessa sur la mer
noire
comme son nom l'indiqué le groupe
d'armées nord formelle elle nord de
l'offensive allemande contre la russie
en juin 1941 au moment de l'attaqué le
groupe d'armées nord été commandée par
le maréchal ritter von hleb et était
composé de deux armées la 16e
initialement commandé par le maréchal
bouche et la dix-huitième dirigée par le
général von couleurs
pour la percée initiale en russie selon
les ordres du plan barbarossa le groupe
nord profitait du soutien d'une
puissante force de blinder le panzer
groupe 4 sous l'autorité du général
hopfner
pour l'appui aérien le groupe nord
pouvaient faire appel à la loupe flotte
un commandée par le général quelle heure
les choucas de la loupiote un serez
chargé des attaques au sol lors de
l'offensive éclair du 22 juin
le soutien naval était assurée par le
puissant groupe de bataille nord sous le
commandement de l'amiral karl ce que
l'on voit ici en train de préparer
l'opération avec ses officiers
supérieurs
non le commandant du groupe d'armées
nord était le maréchal von kaiser qui
avait commandé le groupe d'armées du
centre il avait attaqué la france avec
succès en 1940 il était épaulé par
plusieurs des plus efficaces officiers
que l'armée allemande comptait dans ses
rangs
évidemment il pouvait s'appuyer sur leur
expérience du combat qui sur le front
ouest mais en dépit des qualités de ses
officiers ce genre d'opération a
rapidement montré ses limites
le succès incontestable du groupe
d'armées nord fut accompli en moins de
24 heures quand ils coupent à la france
en 2
[Applaudissements]
pour le grand assaut contre la russie le
groupe d'armées nord pouvait compter sur
plus de 800 mille hommes organisés en
trois divisions blindées 3 d'infanterie
motorisée et trois divisions de sécurité
le groupe d'armées nord n'était
aucunement le mastodonte blindé comme
l'a évoqué la légende les quatre
cinquièmes de ses soldats devaient aller
au combat à pied comme ceux de napoléon
un peu plus d'un siècle auparavant
en 1941 la mécanisation n'était pas
encore dominante
le groupe d'armées nord avait besoin de
deux cent mille chevaux pour tracter ses
canons et son matériel
le groupe d'armées pouvait déployer 1200
canon en termes d'avions il était
comparativement plus faiblement équipés
que les groupes sud et centre mais ils
pouvaient compter sur 600 blindés et 430
avions
ce
le nord pourrait être considérée elle
bien des égards comme le plus pauvre
comparé au groupe sud essence de mai
initialement bien qu'il était témoin
important il réussit à atteindre ses
objectifs fin juillet avec beaucoup
d'habileté et plus rapidement que les
autres groupes d'armées allemand
sans doute parce que moins important un
certain degré il était de meilleure
qualité que les autres formations
allemandes et le terrain qu'il devait
couvrir été moins difficile que celui
des deux autres groupes en particulier
celui du sud le groupe d'armées nord
devait se charger du front nord ouest
qui était sous le commandement de
kouznetsov
en théorie les forces russes étaient
plus importante et mieux équipés avec
des chars des canons et des avions en
pratique l'armée rouge dans son ensemble
s'est avéré démoralisés par les tensions
internes
très mal préparé la plupart du matériel
russe de surcroît était obsolète ou hors
service
le résultat fut que lors des premiers
face à face il n'y pas vraiment de
combat
[Musique]
pendant les premières étapes de sa
campagne le groupe d'armées nord déferla
sur les états baltes la lituanie et
l'estonie tombant rapidement
[Musique]
cette avancée éclair fut fêtée avec joie
par les citoyens des villes comme riga
où la population estonienne considéré
les militaires allemands comme des
libérateurs
un des grands défis de la guerre
maritime tout au long de la campagne a
consisté à tenter de supprimer
l'activité navale soviétique en
mouvement des milliers de mines
une mission qui continuait être
effectués même sous la menace aérienne
ces navires du groupe de bataille de
cars continuer à poser des mines en
dépit des attaques de l'aviation de
l'armée rouge
sur terre la présence d'une puissante
forces blindées le panzer groupe 4
apporta au groupe d'armées nord une
grande partie du soutien indispensable
lors des percées et des avancées en
russie
illfurth engagé en soutien du groupe
d'armées nord les chars du panzer groupe
4 joué un rôle déterminant mais même
avec les panzers les avance rapide de
juin juillet furent stoppés par les
solides défenses de la ligne staline
rencontré en août et début septembre
aucun groupe d'armées allemande ne
pouvait se permettre de perdre des chars
il ne pouvait d'ailleurs se permettre de
perdre quoi que ce soit
en fait les conditions de départ de la
guerre à l'est subir un coup sévère le
panzer groupe iv fut retirée du groupe
nord dans les premières phases de la
guerre de juillet août à la fin
septembre ce n'était pas trop grave mais
en 1942 il n'allait plus de même
il est facile de penser que la perte du
panzer groupe 4 en septembre 1941 fut
directement responsable de l'échec du
groupe d'armées nord à s'emparer de son
objectif stratégique leningrad et ses
spatules sempot l'espagne n'est pas si
simple je n'ai fait que la difficulté de
la mission c'est-à-dire s'emparer d'une
grande ville bien défendus comme lanning
grade aurait été facilitée par le panzer
groupe 4
et sa réaffectation n'a pas aidé la
cause du groupe nord
rive est de la puissance de feu qui lui
aurait permis de cerner la ville de
leningrad
c'est de l'isoler
la disparition du groupe panzer 4 était
un signe avant coureur des événements à
venir démontrant à l'évidence que le
groupe nord et est considérée comme le
parent pauvre des trois groupes d'armées
allemand
il fut rapidement clair que cette unité
ne devait pas s'attendre à recevoir de
réapprovisionnement sous quelque forme
que ce soit et que le groupe allait
devoir effectuer l'essentiel de sa
campagne avec pratiquement aucune
réserve à sa disposition
tout laissait à croire que les batailles
décisives du front est aurait lieu
ailleurs
de façon générale les forces étaient
adaptés à leurs objectifs immédiats ce
que le groupe nord n'avait atteint les
événements l'ont démontré
ce n'était pas un parent pauvre quel que
soit le sens de ces mots c'était un
commandement un conflit était réussi à
atteindre les objectifs que hitler lui
avait fixés c'est-à-dire s'emparer des
pays baltes ou foncé droit sur leningrad
et faire des états baltes des bases pour
les prochaines opérations en russie
cependant il est juste de dire qu'à
partir d'octobre ickler commencent à
hésiter entre l'ukraine qui était un
objectif stratégique et moscou qui était
un objectif politique
le conteneur de 20 l'enfant s'en vont en
termes d'allocation de ressources pour
l'accomplissement de ses objectifs
stratégiques à savoir prendre leningrad
il est juste de dire que l'échec du haut
commandement allemand à l'approvisionner
empêcha le groupe nord de réussir sa
mission
au nord les combats sur la ligne staline
furent un véritable cauchemar
les pertes allemandes atteignait les
niveaux de celle de la première guerre
mondiale
mais après une série de féroces
batailles au cours desquelles la
division ss se distingua
particulièrement la ligne staline fut
finalement brisé à la fin du mois d'août
et le groupe nord s'y engouffra
[Musique]
le principal problème pour les allemands
à ce moment là fut l'apparition sur le
champ de bataille du chat en moyens t34
et du lourd qu avait un
ces deux machines étaient nettement
supérieurs aux chars allemands et
résister à la plupart des armées
allemandes antichar spécialement aux
canons de 37 mm les plus utilisés
le général eran raus qui combattit avec
le groupe d'armées nord laisse un récit
précis de la première rencontre avec les
nouveaux blindés russes
alors harry va soudainement pour la
première fois un bataillon de chars
lourds et demi d'un type encore inconnue
les chars bousculèrent le régiment
d'infanterie blindée et déboulèrent dans
les positions d'artillerie les
projectiles de toutes les armes de
défense à l'exception du 88 mm
antiaériens rebondissait sur l'épais
blindage ennemis les 100 chars allemands
furent incapables de s'opposer aux vins
mastodonte russe et subir des pertes
plusieurs chars tchèque l'été 36 qui
s'était enlisé dans les champs en raison
de problèmes mécaniques furent aplati
par les monstres russe
le même sort fut réservé à une batterie
d'obusiers moyen de 150 mm qui continue
a pourtant attiré jusqu'à la dernière
minute
en dépit de nombreux impacts directs à
des distances de 200 m les obus furent
incapables de mettre ne serait-ce qu'un
seul char hors de combat la situation
devient critique
seuls les 88 réussir à détruire une
poignée de cave et un russe et forcèrent
les autres à se retirer dans les bois
la seule lueur d'espoir pour la
wehrmacht était que les nouveaux chars
russes étaient encore peu nombreux que
leurs tactiques de combat était sommaire
et leur formation éparpillés ce qui
offrait des possibilités d'engagement la
route de leningrad demeurait donc
ouverte
une faute dans les deux premiers mois de
l'opération barbarossa en juin 1941
je pense qu'il est juste de dire que le
groupe noor a mieux réussi que les
groupes centre et sud
le groupe d'armées centre a
remarquablement réussi à détruire
complètement les unités qui tentèrent de
l'affronter car il avait la capacité de
le faire avec efficacité
le groupe nord en revanche est celui qui
a mené à bien la fin juillet toutes les
opérations que le haut commandement
allemand lui avait confié
[Musique]
il ya pratiquement tout le front russe
du nord ouest il élimina deux armées
russes et déferla jusqu'aux abords de
leningrad et soit arabe ce cas c'était
une sacrée réussite
la chute du front ouest se lier tic
était par contre une vraie catastrophe
pour la mer rouge ce qui conduisit
staline au bord du désespoir emmanuel
spect je pense que
c'est par son efficacité que le groupe
noor a été capable de mettre la pression
sur les soviétiques
de leningrad au début de septembre était
très menacé
[Musique]
alors que le groupe nord fonçait vers
leningrad la confusion régnait de très
nombreux russes avaient été faits
prisonniers et beaucoup de soldats
désorganisé s'était fait coincer dans ce
qui s'est appelé la poche d'auragne
mboum sur la côte à l'ouest de leningrad
la poste de radio mais c'est une bande
de terrain tenu par les russes c'était
une zone qui ne fut jamais prises par le
groupe d'armées nord est qui s'avéra
être une épine dans leur flanc
lorsque le groupe d'armées nord a
déferlé sur l'union soviétique en juin
1941 il a balayé la très grande zone
rapidement fonçant vers le nord
détruisent en repoussant les armées
soviétiques
move
mais une petite partie de la viiie armée
soviétique qui avait subi de lourdes
pertes pendant l'attaqué fut repoussé
droit sur la côte
à l'intérieur de la poste à aniane boom
des éléments de la viiie armée furent
bloqués durant trois ans
cette poche fini par être d'une grande
importance stratégique
la zone d'auragne album permis aux
russes de protéger l'île de cronstadt
l'île de kronstadt était vital pour la
base navale à l'ouest de leningrad elle
permettait aux troupes soviétiques de la
région à la marine et à l'armée de terre
d'empêcher les forces allemandes du
groupe d'armées nord d'effectuer un
blocus total de leningrad facilitant
ainsi le passage du ravitaillement aux
assiégés
le 4 septembre 1940 le lieutenant darius
du 1er régiment de panzers prévint son
quartier général par radio que son unité
avait atteint leningrad
des unités du groupe nord sont parait
dechy seul bourgue à l'est de leningrad
d'autres unités et leurs alliés finlande
est arrivée par le nord
les troupes allemandes cuper la voie
ferrée menant à leningrad le sort de la
ville et celui de ses trente division
semblait scellé
contrairement à ce à quoi ils
s'attendaient les hommes du groupe nord
ne rassure pas l'ordre de mener une
attaque massive contre la ville
après une série de batailles sévère dans
les environs hitler de façon surprenante
donna l'ordre à ses troupes de m
leningrad en état de siège
peut-être craignait-il des explosions
contrôlées à distance que les russes
avaient utilisé de façon très efficace à
kiev
c'est une décision qui provoque encore
aujourd'hui beaucoup de débats
non il ya deux explications possibles
pour l'échec du groupe nord à prendre
leningrad
la première est un conflit de priorité
entre hitler et le haut commandement
militaire
qui empêcha le groupe nord d'obtenir les
ressources nécessaires pour prendre la
ville rapide
de la seconde est la réaction d'hitler à
l'expérience vécue par la sixième armée
à kiev c'est en août et septembre 1941
il craignait que les troupes ne
deviennent vulnérables en s'introduisant
dans les rues des cités comme kiev
moscou ou leningrad
sironi de l'histoire on sait ce qui
s'est passé à partir de 1941 du côté de
la ville de stalingrad
mais en 1941 hitler était terriblement
réticents engagé les troupes
d'infanterie dans les zones urbaines où
il était à la merci de contre attaque
soviétique ou de guérilla urbaine
la supériorité militaire allemande ne
pouvait pas s'affirmer dans ces
conditions puisqu'elle avait été pensé
pour les combats ouvert dans la campagne
soviétique
[Musique]
à partir du début du siège de leningrad
une ligne de front relativement stable
commence à se dessiner dans le secteur
nord lequel était adjacent à l'ale
gauche du groupe d'armées du centre
la seizième armées combattent est sur le
flanc droit du secteur nord à proximité
du flanc gauche du groupe d'armées du
sud les deux parties allaient rester
très proches l'une de l'autre sur le
front est pendant toute la durée de la
guerre
le déroulement du siège de leningrad
démontre que le secteur nord était
vraiment considéré comme secondaire
les hommes du groupe nord était
convaincu qu'il combattait dans une
guerre de pauvres
les pertes sur le front russe avait été
énorme mais seulement 60 7000 hommes
furent affectés au groupe nord alors que
131000 alerte au centre et 119 milo
groupe d'armées sud
[Musique]
lorsqu'il fallut affecter des divisions
de réserve fraîche la situation fut
encore moins favorable des vingt-et-une
nouvelle division envoyé au front par le
haut commandement à l'automne 1941
seulement trois furent affectés au
groupe d'armées nord
c'était une indication sur la suite
prévisible des événements à venir
un des atouts inattendue pour ce groupe
d'armées fut le soutien occasionnel
qu'il reçut des unités navales
allemandes opérant dans la baltique
puisque l'un de ses flancs était au bord
de la mer baltique le groupe d'armées
nord était le seul qui pouvait compter
sur un appui sérieux de la kriegsmarine
la marine allemande a joué un grand rôle
dans la guerre entre soviétiques et
allemand
lorsqu'ils arrivèrent à la baltique les
allemands se hâtèrent de la couvrir de
champs de mines
en d'autres termes il piégeait relais
sous marin soviétique là où il se
trouvait ces allemandes le long de la
côte privé la flotte de la baltique de
ses bases
cette flotte étaient rassemblés autour
de leningrad son rôle en 1941 42 étaient
simplement d'apporter son soutien grâce
à la puissance de feu de ses plus gros
navires
la 18ème armés impliqués dans un grand
nombre d'opérations amphibies pour
s'emparer des îles sur la baltique subi
d'importantes pertes ce qui fut très
dommageable les ressources étant
sévèrement limité
durant toute la guerre le manque de
renfort limites a les options
stratégiques pour le commandement du
groupe d'armées cette situation exige à
une grande habilité pour jongler entre
les différentes divisions disponibles
afin de maintenir un front constant
autour de leningrad et cependant
pratiquement trois ans
leningrad était assiégée au sens strict
du terme
les allemands avaient bloqué la ville et
ses faubourgs mais ce siège n'a jamais
été totale
finlandais sont en partie responsables
de cette situation
le maréchal à 9m de l'armée finlandaise
avait clairement annoncé qu'il ne
prendrait aucune part dans une attaque
directe sur leningrad
c'était une des conditions pour que la
finlande entre en guerre
s'ils avaient à l'esprit autant la
situation politique que la situation
militaire car les relations entre
finlandais et russes étaient une longue
histoire
[Musique]
le résultat était que les allemands et
les finlandais n'était pas en mesure de
couper totalement leningrad du reste du
monde
les forces russes pouvaient
approvisionner la ville par le lac
ladoga au nord-est de la ville
depuis l'hiver 1942 la voie ferrée à
l'est de leningrad relié à leningrad au
reste de l'union soviétique qui était
donc en mesure de fournir les troupes et
les approvisionnements permettant aux
habitants de la ville de survivants
je me suis entretenu avec l'un des
négociateurs soviétique à propos des
pourparlers de paix entre soviétiques et
finlandais plus tard pendant la guerre
il disait que les russes n'avaient pas
oublié ce que les finlandais avait fait
ou plutôt n'avait pas fait mouche car si
les finlandais avait avancé un peu plus
et fermer le siège cela aurait signifié
la mort de leningrad
après la guerre on découvrira la lecture
des journaux de marche des 16e et 18e
armés que les commandants des deux
formations avaient interdit même lors
des périodes calmes le retrait de la
moindre unité du front même pour
effectuer une période de repos
il était préférable de conserver la
division sur le front est de la signer
un secteur voisin une unité de réserve
qui auraient été retirés du front nord
est est certaine d'être réquisitionné
par le haut commandement et réaffectés
sur des points plus cruciaux le front
central où le front sud
bien que le front nord fut considéré
comme un front d'importance secondaire
rien ne peut laisser à penser qu'il ne
s'y passait rien il y eu de terribles
combats sur des terrains difficiles avec
d'immenses marais quelques rares août et
d'immenses étendues de forêt
infranchissable
c'était un véritable cauchemar
logistique
le groupe d'armées nord et ses divisions
affrontait des conditions vraiment
difficiles sur le front est où le climat
et le terrain conditionnait les
opérations
effectivement il faisait vraiment froid
c'était marécageux et boul ça c'est le
premier point le second point c'est que
ce n'était pas très riche en route donc
les transports logistique était très
difficile
il serait faux de dire que c'était une
guerre différentes c'était bien une
guerre tout court mais qui s'est déroulé
différemment
les batailles étaient sauvages les
pertes du côté russe on était énorme
le groupe nord et les formations de
l'armée rouge ont écrit là une tragédie
sanglante
[Musique]
en octobre 41 les premières attaques de
partisans commencèrent à causer de
sérieuses difficultés aux zones arrière
ces attaques étaient graves car le sous
développement de l'infrastructure en
russie signifiait qu'il y avait peu de
routes ou voies ferrées utilisable à la
place de celle que les partisans bloqués
[Musique]
l'hiver russe était aussi un cauchemar
sur l'ensemble du front mais c'est le
groupe d'armées du nord qui a subi la
brutalité du plus extrêmes d hiver russe
il est impossible d'imaginer la dureté
des combats dans le féroce hiver du nord
de la russie
[Musique]
le nordique france le front nord
subissait un froid implacable
c'était une zone où le nord de la
norvège la finlande et l'union
soviétique se rejoignent
ils étaient caractérisés
particulièrement lors des mois d'hiver
par des conditions de combat ralentit
ce qui aboutit à l'opération rhein dire
à l'opération cold fox c'est à
l'opération silver fox
la 20e armée de montagne blindés en
conjonction avec les alliés finlandais
chercheur envahir les régions les plus
au nord de l'union soviétique en
particulier pour couper la voie ferrée
entre les ports arctiques et l'intérieur
de l'union soviétique
cependant la 14e armée soviétique
s'avéra dès le début être un opposant
intraitable
du début de l'opération jusqu'au moment
où la 20e armée fut réduite en 1941 elle
souffrit du plus haut taux de perte de
tous les groupes d'armées qui prirent
pas à l'opération barbarossa
la 20e armée de montagne n'était pas
prioritaire pour le haut commandement
allemand
allemand et finlandais n'arrivait pas à
lancer une opération décisive contre les
soviétiques
en plus des conditions géographiques et
climatiques difficiles l'esprit combatif
de l'armée rouge qui faisait face au
groupe nord n'étaient pas moins fort que
celui observable dans les autres
secteurs
le siège de leningrad est devenu
synonyme d'endurance et de souffrance il
lui aussi de violents combats lors de
batailles mineurs qui se sont déroulées
sur les lignes établies autour de
leningrad
outre ces batailles assez statique il eu
des affrontements terrible autour d'eux
des nuances que dans le secteur de la
sixième armée de 1941 à 1943
au début 43 le saillant de d'aignan sq
avait commencé à s'effondrer jusqu'à
ressembler un étrange champignons
protubérants dans les lignes russes
sous la pression de plus en plus forte
les russes hitler fut forcé de renoncer
à la politique de pas de retraite
deignan ce que fut évacuée au cours
d'une opération superbement organisée
grâce à laquelle 80 mille soldats
allemands échappèrent à une capture
certaine
mieux ce que fut le siège le plus long
est un épisode militaire singulier
les forces allemandes encerclé et piéger
par les russes devaient être ravitaillée
ne pouvait pas être ravitaillée par
terre
il fallait donc le faire par
rff assura qu'elle pouvait le faire et
qu'il n'y avait aucun doute à ce propos
finalement en 1943 les forces allemandes
réussir à percer un couloir grâce auquel
l'encerclement d'un des nuances que pris
fin avec succès
ce qui est intéressant ce sont les
leçons que le haut commandement allemand
et la luftwaffe en particulier en ont
tiré à savoir qu'il était possible de
ravitailler des forces allemandes en
cercle et on a quand même le prochain
siège allait être celui de stalingrad
c'est une des raisons pour laquelle la
sixième armée n'a pas tenté de
s'échapper du piège de stalingrad
lorsqu'il est devenu clair qu'il lui
était possible de le faire sexton était
qu'ils l'air croyait que la sixième
armée pouvait tenir la poche en étant
soutenu par la luftwaffe il se servit
bien sûr de la poche de déviance comme
preuve évidente
la situation de défiance qui était
cependant différente l'approvisionnement
possible de la poche pendant les mois
d'été le nombre de soldats moins de 90
milles contre 200 milles piégée à
stalingrad etc
il est certain que la poche de déviances
que cité par hitler joue un rôle négatif
dans l'histoire de la sixième armée son
encerclement et son anéantissement à
stalingrad
bien qu'ayant été proche de la victoire
le groupe d'armées nord n'a jamais été
capable de fermer définitivement le
cercle autour de leningrad
le haut commandement continua à déplacer
les divisions loin du secteur nord pour
alimenter les autres secteurs plus en
danger
le résultat de cette politique sur deux
fronts fut qu'une offensive soviétique
massive en janvier 1944 fini par briser
la résistance du groupe nord est du même
coup les taux autour de leningrad
[Musique]
après la fin du siège de la ville en
1944 les forces du groupe nord
reculèrent vers des lignes de défense
inachevé connu sous le nom de ligne
panthères
la ligne panthère et c'est une série de
fortifications qui s'étendait jusqu'aux
régions centrales et sud de l'union
soviétique depuis une vallée qui
couraient entre le lac devina et le lag
skov près de la ville de narva sur la
côte de la baltique en estonie
il était prévu que grâce à ces
fortifications les troupes allemandes en
train de reculer profiterait d'un peu de
répit
ce qui leur permettrait de contenir
l'armée soviétique le temps que les
unités blindées et aériennes soient
remises en état et retourne au combat
pour inverser le sort des armes par leur
nombre
cependant la ligne panthères fut à peine
occuper les armées allemandes ayant subi
de nombreux revers n'avait pas assez de
troupes pour tenir la ligne avec
efficacité 2 dans les zones de la ligne
où les défenses adéquates avaient été
préparées avec un nombre suffisant de
soldats et des avions disponibles elle
s'avéra être un obstacle presque
infranchissable pour les armées
soviétiques
cela laisse à penser que bien préparé et
organisé avec un plan cohérent la ligne
panthères aurait pu être tenus ce qui
aurait causé de sérieuses complications
aux armées soviétiques
la ligne panthères n'allait pouvoir
fournir qu'une solution temporaire au
problème de plus en plus important du
groupe d'armées nord
la destruction du groupe d'armées
centres voisins en juin 1944 crozat un
grand espace dans les lignes allemandes
et les seuls flux endroits du groupe
nord vulnérables aux attaques soviétique
hitler fut forcé d'effectuer une autre
série de retraits
ils furent obligés de battre en retraite
en relativement bon ordre vers
l'allemagne tout en subissant une série
d' attaque la plus notable étant celle
pour la défense de narva en 1944
narva narva a joué un rôle important non
seulement lors de la guerre germano
soviétique mais dans l'histoire de la
russie
nava fut le lieu de la monumentale
défaite en 1700 face au suédois
l'avait est essentiellement une
importance opérationnel car c'était la
porte d'entrée vers l'estonie
de fait les allemands ce qui tenait
narva été initialement répartis en douze
divisions constituant les défenseurs de
narva c'est à dire un groupe
spécialement formé pour l'occasion des
fans venant la défense de narva fut un
combat terrible
une percée à cet endroit aurait mis en
danger toutes les troupes allemandes des
pays baltes de l'estonie et de la
lituanie les ss ainsi que la division
280 et la division 58 quittèrent le
front de leningrad sous le commandement
du général de gaulle valroff entre
janvier et mars 44
leur faible taux de perte n'est pas le
fruit de manoeuvres tactiques
sophistiqué de formations blindées
j'aime les unités allemandes et le
contingent de volontaires ss ont été
sauvés par le printemps précoce de mars
1944 ce qui déclencha des inondations et
des torrents de boue dans lesquelles les
chars soviétiques semble huerre
l'incroyable résistance offerte par le
groupe d'armées denard vain une
formation improvisé tirer des maigres
effectifs du groupe nord représente un
exemple spectaculaire d'improvisation
militaire et tient la comparaison avec
d'autres bataille défensive mener
ailleurs en russie et en italie
en octobre 44 la situation autour de
narva était devenu sans espoir mais à la
différence des innombrables garnison
acquis hitler avait exigé de tenir à
n'importe quel prix le groupe narva
réussit à s'échapper et à rejoindre le
groupe d'armées nord
la retraite permanente et est désormais
à l'ordre du jour alors que le groupe
reculait à travers les états baltes vers
l'allemagne
mais le groupe d'armées nord n'allait
jamais parvenir à la maison
alors que l'armée rouge foncé vers
berlin
les hommes du groupe nord furent
finalement coincé dans la péninsule du
courlande en lituanie
l'aller reste du groupe subir les
attaques soviétique pendant six mois il
fut assiégé de la fin octobre 44 jusqu'à
mai 45
en janvier 45 les deux armées qui avait
servi depuis 1941 sous la bannière du
groupe d'armées nord fut rebaptisé
groupe d'armées de courlande et la
dénomination chèrement acquise deux
groupes nord fut transférée à un
assemblage disparate d'unités déconfite
placés sous le commandement d'une
succession ininterrompue de chefs
temporaire
l'esprit des hommes du groupe nord
demeurait en courlande
le fait est étrange c'est que ces
divisions allemands qui se sont frayés
un chemin en courlande ont été mis à
l'écart
elles étaient bloqués là et elle ne
pouvait plus rien faire
elle ne pouvait plus apporter leur
contribution au combat
par bien des aspects ce fut une action
en pure perte et irresponsable de la
part d' hitler
c'était une force considérable qui
aurait pu apporter une réelle
contribution si elle avait été
disponible
n'était simplement pas là elle était
d'ailleurs
la décision des soviétiques de les
laisser là était assez délicate
c'est pourtant ce qu'ils ont fait plus
tard
en dépit de tout ce que l'armée rouge
leur expédier les éléments survivants
des 16e et 18e armées désormais désigné
groupe d'armées de courlande
continuèrent a résisté à toutes les
tentatives menées pour les amener à se
rendre
les combats pour la courlande furent
terribles
ce n'était pas comme pour les fronts est
et ouest d'importantes armée se lançant
à travers les frontières sont
d'impressionnantes opérations
sophistiquées
en courlande les allemands coincé furent
graduellement et sûrement d'une manière
irrémédiable doucement repoussé dans une
sorte de cul de sage par l'armée rouge
ils furent soutenus jusqu'à la fin par
les navires de la kriegsmarine qui
réussirent à évacuer quelques divisions
rappelé en allemagne à l'occasion il
parvint même à cheminer quelques
renforts vraiment indispensable
oui la marine allemande avait un rôle
important
lorsque l'armée rouge a commencé à
avancer le long de la côte de la
baltique pour filer dans l'est de la
crue ce la marine allemande avait tout à
gagner à contenir les opérations navales
soviétique qui commençait à s'étendre
plus important encore il avait un
challenge crucial tenter d'évacuer le
plus de civils et deux militaires
allemands possible pour les ramener sur
le territoire allemand
la kriegsmarine tenta de limiter les
conséquences d'une défaite finale
maintenant inévitable
le rôle de la marine allemande est
incontournable pour expliquer pourquoi
les unités allemandes ont combattu
vaillamment
jusqu'aux confins du territoire de la
courlande
la péninsule était d'un point de vue
militaire sans intérêt
bien sûr beaucoup de chefs allemand fin
44 des bus 45 demandait constamment
éclair d'abandonner cette péninsule
et de libérer les 26 division qui se bat
et là afin qu'elle puisse venir
renforcer les défenses des régions qui
étaient d'une importance militaires
majeures comme la prusse orientale
jane d'un autre côté la marine allemande
utilisait la baltique comme zone
d'entraînement pour ces commandant de
sous-marin
de nice le chef de la marine à cette
époque considéré que conserver le golf
de gdansk sur la baltique est essentiel
pour entraîner ses commandant de
sous-marin
lisez le nouveau et très puissant sous
marin type 21 que la marine a engagé
jusqu aux derniers jours de la guerre
traille trinh thi
donc la marine a joué un rôle
déterminant dans le fait que les unités
allemandes aient combattu si longtemps
pour la péninsule de la courlande
cependant à la fin la même kriegsmarine
qui avait été la raison de la bataille
de courlande et avait acheminé les
troupes allemandes jusque là fut ensuite
forcé de les évacuer de la péninsule et
d'abandonner la zone sans obtenir le
moindre bénéfice stratégique
les survivants de l'ancien groupe
d'armées nord conservèrent leur cohésion
et leur capacité de combat jusqu'à la
reddition finale du 8 mai 1945
pratiquement quatre ans après leur
arrivée en russie
ce jour là deux sans trois mille hommes
commencèrent leur longue marche vers la
captivité
beaucoup n'en revinrent jamais et les
autres furent maintenues comme
travailleurs forcés jusqu'en 1955 un
prix élevé à payer pour leur longue
résistance
[Musique]
les trois immenses groupe d'armées que
hitler envoyées en russie le groupe nord
fut celui qui réussit le mieux atteindre
les objectifs qu'on lui avait fixés
bien que cette campagne s'acheva
finalement sur un échec les hommes du
groupe d'armées nord avait conservé leur
cohésion
quelques unités réussir l'exploit de
servir dans le même groupe d'armées
pendant les quatre années de la guerre
en russie
[Musique]